- YOU READY, HOMIE?
- HELLS YEAH.
- LET'S TAKE
THESE [bleep]ERS OUT.
- HOLD UP.
NAH...
- WHAT?
- WE GOTTA
GO BACK HOME, MAN.
- WHY?
- I POOPED MY PANTS.
- WHAT?
- JUST NOW.
I JUST POOPED MY PANTS.
- YOU--YOU GOT DIARRHEA?
- HELL NO, MAN,
I AIN'T GAY.
WE GOTTA GO HOME RIGHT NOW,
MAN, LET ME CHANGE MY DRAWERS.
- MAN, THE DUDES WE TRYING
TO SMOKE IS RIGHT THERE.
- MAN, HOW YOU WANT ME
TO SMOKE SOMEBODY
WHEN I GOT POOP
IN MY PANTS?
- ARE YOU SURE
YOU POOPED 'EM?
- AM I SURE? [bleep], AM I SURE?
- YEAH.
- YES.
THAT IS POOP IN MY PANTS.
- THAT'S NASTY, MAN.
- IT'S NATURAL, MAN.
- FOR A THREE YEAR OLD.
NOT FOR A HARDCORE GANGSTA.
- SEE, IF YOU WERE
MY REAL FRIEND, THOUGH,
YOU WOULDN'T MAKE
SUCH A BIG DEAL OUT OF IT.
- WOULDN'T MAKE
SUCH A BIG DEAL OUT OF IT?
[bleep], YOU A GROWN-ASS MAN
WHO JUST [bleep] IN HIS DRAWERS.
- OH, SNAP.
- NO, YOU DIDN'T.
[bleep], YOU JUST [bleep]
YOUR PANTS AGAIN.
- DON'T JUDGE.
- YOU NEED TO GET OUTTA MY CAR
AND GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
- OKAY, I SEE HOW IT IS.
SEE, I WOULDN'T DO THAT
TO YOU, THOUGH.
- [bleep], YOU NEVER WOULD
HAVE TO DO THAT TO ME,
BECAUSE UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD I EVER [bleep] MY PANTS.
[cocks gun]
UH--[gasps]
I'M SORRY I JUDGED YOU.
- APOLOGY ACCEPTED.